Elizabeth Blackburn won the Nobel Prize
for her discoveries at the molecular
level of how the ends of chromosomes for
so-called telomeres work it's the
fundamental mechanism so this anything
Dao I'd love to meet Elizabeth Blackburn
she's a hobart girl like me I've come
from the same small town in Australia
and she's gone on to pretty great things
the ends of the chromosomes consist of a
special DNA sequence that is repeated
many many times the enzyme telomerase
which makes the ends of chromosomes is
really important because if you have not
enough to lama raise the cells stop
dividing and this is basically what you
call aging blood when you have too much
of it the DNA is not stable anymore and
that causes cancer and that's why
telomeres are so important so we're not
where are you from and tell me all about
where did you come from different parts
of the world from the University of ring
and suppose yes and I'm interested in
sequences come from home batting I'm
just allowed to submit my PhD a I'm to
malaria research they're looking at good
host acceptability yes different
therapies yes after submission they come
over and work at pasture I arrived on
Saturday and already yes two hours later
I was discussing with different parts of
the world about science and
what makes these sad is when people get
very protective about the results and
they won't talk about it until it's
published right so I just decided I
spill the beans
and basically I talk and I don't think
there's ever been a time when it was you
know a mistake to have done that but you
want to go and you know just share and
hotel in the other guy no no you've
gotta wait I know my feeling is that's
probably a mistake in the long run and
probably even in the middle run as well
and it might seem as though Oh somebody
sort of took my idea but in fact it
never really happened to over you know
they they might publish something
similar and maybe they published first
and Messier right that you published and
that in the end it prevails and I think
it's real worth it to talk science now
is this industrial driven application
driven maybe also hypothesis forced
experiment again and again until you get
the expected result and so my take on it
is what happened was that I think there
was a lot of really ghastly clinical
research that was being done right it
was really awful stuff and so then
people started to say look you have to
have a hypothesis and you have to do it
and so then the clinical things were
started to get sort of formulated here's
my hypothesis and my job is to prove it
know when science your job is to see if
you can disprove the hypothesis that's
real science and but as you say it got
sort of distorted into this here's my
idea and now I'm going to do everything
I can to make my day to fit this which
is so distorting and I think
grant-writing because when you slide for
funding you already have to you know
let's get this clear about you know
grants I mean I have a very clear idea
there's there's two worlds there's
called science and there's called grants
okay they coexist they are not the same
and the biggest mistake is two mistakes
or two for the one for the other you
can't sit and write a grant application
and say well I think I might find a new
enzyme doesn't go down
well with the review section it's okay
but you can have wonderful funding which
opens up the possibility which says
let's look at how telomeres work and I'm
so grateful to a funding agency like the
NIH that said you have a grant that's
called structure and function of
telomeres and within that I could run
with the question the person who used to
run all the grants from the NIH
he once said what's happened is that
people start mistaking the specific aims
for the science and he said we all
understood that you take the money and
run okay but that's the idea you take
the money and you run with the science
and he and he said the tragedy now is
that study sections the house you know
they got very soft pickings at oh they
didn't do their specific aims but the
whole point was nobody's ever penalized
for going and doing something
interesting and not finishing all their
specific aims when somebody comes to you
with a really interesting question that
just grabs you and you think that person
is good at that kind of research go for
it so that we started a collaboration
and this was wonderful because our
friends in the UCSF Department of
Psychiatry were very interested in
chronic stress and we found low and
behold that we could interact and show
than people in which chronic stress by
the way is a known risk factor for
common diseases such as cardiovascular
that telomere shortness was associated
with chronic stress when I started
collaborating with ELISA who's working
with people who are in really awfully
hard situations but you know mothers of
chronically ill children caregivers of
you know their husband or you know a
partner or somebody who has dementia I
mean these people are under major
long-term stress the patients are being
looked after and the caregivers are
being ignored Jerry my PhD thesis I
developed a method which enables the
analysis if genes are switched on or if
they are switched off the great
advantage of this method is that it
works on repetitive DNA such as
telomeres we had this question that we
want to answer yes but there was no
method okay yes to use
it was kind of risky because I
established a new method what was the
method what was it about we call it epic
coming and it's about DNA methylation
and repetitive inferences yes and with
the methods that are established so far
you can't look for DNA methylation
patterns so at individual repeats next
to each other if they are epigenetically
linked on the symbolic on the same
moment you also using combing - yeah yes
what was the EPI part then yeah we
before doing the fish yes we do an email
of fluorescence with specific antibodies
against DNA methylation and also against
you know hydroxymethyl II got it - big
yes so yeah having the hydroxymethyl C's
and the five seven C's but it exactly
her recent research showed that
environmental factors such as stress
shortened telomeres and other studies
showed that environmental factors are
able to switch genes off and on so
therefore I hope that she can use my
method to analyze if genes around the
telomeres can be switched off or on by
environmental factors I would love to do
that with this one extremely yes if the
link of these environmental factors yes
might be your name already show that DNA
methylation plays an important role in
stress development yes and your method
might be even more important because
people have been looking at DNA
methylation in the sub telomeric regions
there was a meeting recently and they
looked at some of the mutants in people
who have very short telomeres and so on
the answer is extremely confusing okay
but of course they weren't using your
method normal methods you measure an
average of all chromosomes and the
average of individual repeats on a
chromosome so what should my measure is
just an average you must imagine you'll
miss the pattern of methylation and
maybe the key yes I'm sure Elizabeth
Blackburn didn't hear about the method I
developed before because it's not
published yet and I'm sure she can use
it in her lab so while I'm working on
malaria search which is an eternity away
from telling me and what Elizabeth does
what I'm looking to Elizabeth for is the
same idea we're both still biologists we
both started with cell biology and with
malaria research we take it through and
try and translate it and that's kind of
an Elizabeth stone she's taken some
basic cell biology and taking it through
to the clinic
we didn't hear what you were doing so
here what malaria but he said this
interesting news instead of timing the
parasite and he takes it over comes easy
clear what about the host factors the
parasite steals host favors and so is an
honest genus throwing this crazy idea
some drugs and now we've got it through
from the cells to the mice in certain
people that someone a pastor to I grow
up the parasites and I try and kill them
with these new drugs and so as a student
being able to take it through and now
looking towards the clinic and how this
is applied in people getting it to the
people that's needed it's an exciting
field but I think the other interesting
thing is you know when do you start
collaborating in terms of you know do
you do it early in your career do you
late I mean I didn't do any of the
clinical stuff till you know the night
late 1990s and and I think you really
have to become very you know you have to
be able to bring something to the table
your your expertise I think you want to
develop a deep expertise so I do it in
phases right so I was very very hard
working early sort of stages and then
and then you know I got pregnant right
and so okay so now our son was born and
so of course now the science got
complicated because now he had to be
back for scheduled you just had to
organize it differently
and you know it's crazy to lose a
scientist because of a few years of when
you know this intensive need for helping
children it seems crazy you throw away a
scientist because that person is going
to be busy with family for just a few
years and then you throw away them being
a scientist for the rest of their lives
doesn't make sense no it was amazing
yeah it was such a great experience yeah
she's all about sharing the ideas rather
than keeping science secret so much in
science now everyone hides what they do
before they publish it she doesn't think
like that at all yes really refreshing
here scientists it says I don't care I'm
gonna share this and let's get the Nuala
each other yeah she instantly realizes
the impact of my established method that
she really liked it and said that it
will answer so many unresolved questions
so even though I don't necessarily work
on epigenetics a wider genetics group
back in Hobart we're doing kind of
similar stuff and Karina's new technique
would be very useful
maybe Karina should come to Australia
yeah I'd love to establish it in
Tasmania and you know educate and
inspire and connect it's all about well
I think Leo and Karina are clearly
clearly terrific you know they have
success written all over them and
they've already done research in which
they've really taken the initiative the
kind of attitude they've had is what's
going to bring them success in the
future